-Il y a parfois des imprévus,
en politique.
Mon invité n'avait pas du tout prévu
de devenir député.
Il siège pourtant à l'Assemblée
depuis 2017.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Fabien Lainé.
-Bonjour.
-Tous les chemins
mènent à la politique.
Vous, c'est votre baby-sitter
qui vous y a emmené.
-Alors, oui, effectivement.
C'était ma nounou,
sur le bassin d'Arcachon,
dont je suis originaire,
qui gardait ma soeur et moi,
et qui s'est présentée
aux élections municipales,
en 89,
et qui donc m'a associé,
en fait,
à son choix politique,
à sa volonté de s'investir
pour l'intérêt général.
Immédiatement, ça m'a plu,
sur les thèmes municipaux,
- j'avais 13 ans -
et de ce qui pouvait toucher
la jeunesse.
Elle m'a appris
tout ce qui était aménagements,
urbanisme,
architecture, paysages...
-Vous faisiez quoi ?
-Elle m'emmenait,
elle m'en parlait,
elle me donnait des cours
d'instruction civique,
comment on est élu,
les responsabilités.
Ca a rythmé mon adolescence,
après.
Arrivé au lycée,
j'ai continué à m'intéresser
à la vie publique.
-Quelques années plus tard,
vous vous êtes présenté
dans cette commune,
Le Teich.
-Une commune à côté d'Arcachon.
-Vous aviez 24 ans,
tête de liste aux municipales.
Vous n'avez pas gagné.
Vous avez siégé
dans l'opposition.
En 2014, vous vous êtes présenté
et avez été élu
dans une autre commune.
Vous aviez déménagé entre-temps.
Vous vous êtes présenté à Sanguinet.
Vous dites
que ce mandat de maire
correspond à votre âme de patron.
C'est quelque chose
que vous retrouvez moins,
dans le mandat de député ?
Expliquez-nous un petit peu
cette idée d'âme de patron.
-J'ai eu la choix d'être le maire
de cette belle commune de Sanguinet
dans les Landes.
Vous prenez des décisions
toute la journée,
avec vos services, avec vos élus,
et donc c'est de l'arbitrage
en permanence.
C'est différent du travail
qu'on va demander
à un parlementaire.
Un parlementaire
vote et amende la loi,
il fait également
du contrôle parlementaire,
de l'influence.
-On va en parler,
mais c'est ce côté
"aux commandes, aux manettes",
qui vous plaisait ?
-Evidemment,
j'étais directeur commercial avant,
et c'est vrai que je gérais
une équipe commerciale,
j'avais des clients,
et il fallait prendre
des décisions aussi,
donc le travail de maire,
même s'il est en faveur
de l'intérêt général,
m'a pas changé
sur ma façon de manager.
Ce sont trois belles années
que j'ai vécues
à la tête de cette commune.
Vraiment, moi, j'étais marqué,
au début, parce qu'en fait,
vous êtes très sollicité
par l'administration.
Le nouveau maire doit se positionner
sur plein de choses.
Le maire est vice-président
de l'intercommunalité.
Vous êtes très attendu.
-C'est une belle commune.
-Oui, 5000 habitants,
20 000 l'été,
on est une petite commune balnéaire.
Il y a déjà 100 salariés,
donc il faut manager,
il faut être à la tête
de cette administration municipale.
-Vous étiez très heureux
dans ce mandat de maire,
mais aux législatives de 2017,
vous êtes devenu le suppléant
de Geneviève Darrieussecq.
A l'époque, vous pensiez
qu'il y avait un risque,
ou une chance, je sais pas,
selon votre point de vue,
que vous deveniez député ?
-Non, tout ça était assez nouveau.
J'étais le 1er maire,
avec Lionel Causse,
il était socialiste,
j'étais centriste,
et on se met à soutenir
Emmanuel Macron
fin 2016.
Les choses font qu'on s'aperçoit
qu'il va devenir
président de la République,
et qu'il va falloir
qu'il y ait des parlementaires,
en tout cas des candidats.
Je souhaitais que ce soit Geneviève
qui se présente
car elle était maire
de Mont-de-Marsan,
une politique éminente
de notre département,
très appréciée,
donc j'ai été la voir en disant :
"Geneviève, vas-y. C'est ton tour."
Elle me dit : "Tu l'as soutenu
depuis le tout début,
"donc tu es légitime pour y aller."
Je venais d'être élu maire
trois ans avant.
J'avais lancé plein de projets,
je me voyais pas partir
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Elle a accepté d'y aller.
Quand elle me l'a demandé,
j'ai dit oui.
-Sans vous dire qu'elle pouvait
devenir ministre.
-Non, elle pensait pas l'être.
-A peine élue,
elle a été nommée ministre
et elle a pas quitté
le gouvernement.
Vous avez siégé en continu, depuis.
Elle a été réélue en 2022
avec toujours vous comme suppléant,
mais elle peut redevenir députée,
si au prochain remaniement,
elle n'est plus ministre.
Est-ce que ça fait pas de vous
un député en sursis ?
-Je suis le plus ancien suppléant
siégeant, de ce que je sais,
donc on apprend à vivre
avec le sursis.
C'est comme ça que ça a été convenu.
Je serais sûrement
un peu nostalgique,
de quitter l'Assemblée nationale,
car j'y ai pris mes marques,
depuis six ans,
en donnant du sens à mon engagement
au niveau national,
et également local,
mais je retrouverais la mairie
avec bonheur.
-Vous avez une formule
qui a retenu mon attention.
Vous dites qu'un député,
c'est un influenceur.
Je suis allé voir
vos réseaux sociaux,
et sur Instagram,
je suis tombé sur ça.
Musique héroïque
...
Musique émouvante
J'aime bien la musique.
C'est "Star Wars",
sur l'examen de la loi
de programmation militaire,
mais là,
vous êtes pas influenceur.
"Député influenceur", c'est quoi ?
-Deux choses :
déjà, ce qui m'a marqué
dès les premiers jours,
c'est en fait, là,
vous prenez plus de décisions.
C'est pas ce qu'on vous demande.
On vous demande
de représenter votre territoire,
d'apporter de la plus-value
au travail législatif.
Il y a des amendements,
également via des rapports,
donc vous allez faire un travail
un peu plus universitaire,
j'oserais dire.
-Ca, c'est l'autre volet, après.
-Vous faites un travail de fond
pour influencer
le travail législatif.
C'est pour ça que je parlais
d'influenceur.
Et en même temps,
moi, ce que j'ai vu,
c'est que nos administrés,
nos électeurs, nos citoyens,
connaissent mal le travail
du parlementaire,
comme je pouvais mal le connaître
avant de l'être.
Je me suis mis
pour modeste mission,
mais au moins là où je suis élu,
de rendre compte de ce que je fais,
et en quoi consiste
mon travail quotidien
de parlementaire,
qu'il s'agisse de représenter
les territoires
et de mon action en commission
de la défense.
-Vous dites qu'un député
doit être un universitaire.
C'est pour ça que quand vous avez
commencé à siéger à l'Assemblée,
vous avez pris des cours d'anglais,
vous avez suivi une formation
en géopolitique,
vous suivez
des cours de l'IHEDN,
l'Institut des hautes études
de la défense nationale.
C'est ça, le côté universitaire ?
-J'ai pas fait de longues études,
j'étais constructeur
de maisons individuelles.
Quand vous siégez
dans des assemblées
qui traitent de questions
de défense, de géopolitique,
- je siège à l'assemblée
parlementaire de l'OTAN -
vous avez le devoir de vous former
et d'être vraiment au point.
L'anglais, effectivement,
quand vous êtes à la défense,
vous avez beaucoup de rencontres
avec nos partenaires étrangers,
européens mais pas seulement,
vous voyagez, vous représentez
le pays,
et à l'assemblée parlementaire,
même si le français
est la langue officielle,
en off, quand vous parlez du Scaf
avec des parlementaires allemands...
-Le futur avion de combat.
-...il faut être aguerri
techniquement sur le fond,
mais également sur la forme.
-Vous êtes spécialisé
sur les questions de défense,
vous avez deux bases aériennes
et un centre de tir de missiles
sur votre circonscription.
Sur la chasse, beaucoup pratiquée
dans les Landes,
est-ce qu'on peut être élu
député des Landes
si on n'est pas chasseur
ou si on est contre la chasse ?
-Je suis favorable à la chasse.
Mon père l'était et ma famille l'est
depuis très longtemps.
On a vraiment ça dans notre ADN.
-Des députés contre la chasse,
vous en connaissez,
dans l'histoire politique
des Landes ?
-Ils feraient pas long feu.
-Oui, c'est ça.
-Mais moi,
j'ai cet attachement à ma terre.
-Sans être chasseur.
-Oui, parce que les chasseurs,
c'est pas l'acte cynégétique,
c'est le côté de contemplation
de la nature,
d'être vigie de l'environnement.
On voit sur la photo Biganon,
qui est un chasseur de sanglier,
mais c'est un écologiste
qui prend soin de nos milieux.
Si jamais il y a une dégradation,
une pollution,
ce sont ces gens-là
qui vont nous le dire.
-C'est pas parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de chasseurs
dans les Landes ?
Ca se résume pas à ça ?
-J'aime beaucoup l'environnement
et les questions
qui touchent
autour de la biodiversité.
On est au coeur du réacteur
sur la biodiversité.
Je plaide pour une vision
scientifique de la chasse,
et non pas affective.
En fonction de l'évolution
des espèces,
on a des quotas qu'on peut chasser
ou pas, et on rationnalise
les choses.
En même temps, la beauté
de la nature est très présente.
La plus grande forêt d'Europe
est dans les Landes.
La chasse est aussi tout ça,
c'est une tradition.
-On pratique la corrida,
dans votre circonscription,
dans votre département des Landes.
Il vous arrive aussi
d'aller en voir.
Vous êtes un aficionado.
Vous vous êtes opposé
à la proposition de loi
d'Aymeric Caron,
qui voulait abolir la corrida.
Vous vous êtes justifié
dans un communiqué :
"En tant qu'élu de la Nation,
"ce n'est pas mon avis qui compte
mais celui des concitoyens
"que je suis censé écouter
et représenter."
Ca veut dire que votre avis
ne compte pas ?
Vos idées, vos valeurs,
votre programme,
ça passe après ce que pensent
vos électeurs ?
Comment vous concevez les choses ?
-La corrida fait partie
de l'identité de ma région.
Y toucher,
quand on est député parisien
et qu'on veut interdire
aux gens du sud-ouest leur pratique,
c'est irritant.
-Dans votre façon
de définir votre conception
du mandat de député,
on a l'impression que ce que pensent
vos électeurs passe avant vos idées.
Quand vous défendez l'exploitation
du pétrole
au-delà de 2040,
- et vous avez des engagements
écolos par ailleurs -
ça peut donner le sentiment
que vous portez des idées...
-Vous voulez dire
"contradictoires" ?
-En harmonie avec vos idées.
-L'affaire du pétrole,
c'est qu'après 2040,
on puisse continuer
à produire du pétrole,
parce qu'on en aura besoin.
Le pétrole qui est produit
en France,
il est trois fois moins émissible
dans nos extractions
que celui qu'on importe.
C'est un choix responsable
en matière d'environnement.
En plus, ceux qui produisent
du pétrole chez moi,
ils chauffent un écoquartier,
ils chauffent des serres,
donc tout ça est plus responsable.
-Vous êtes pas influenceur,
vous êtes lobbyiste, en fait.
-Non, j'essaye d'être rationnel.
L'élu doit être rationnel
avant tout.
On l'a vu pendant la crise du Covid,
on est partis
dans des délires affectifs
alors que l'idée,
c'est d'être rationnel.
Quand on est rationnel,
on sert l'intérêt général.
-On va passer à notre quiz,
si vous le voulez bien.
L'idée, c'est que vous allez devoir
compléter les phrases
que je vais proposer.
"Ma première prise de parole
"dans l'hémicycle..."
-Je pense qu'ils n'ont entendu
que les voyelles.
J'étais tellement ému
qu'il n'y avait plus les consonnes.
-Un peu stressé ?
-Extrêmement stressé au moment
où j'arrive à la tribune.
Avant, ça allait, et d'un coup,
grosse d'émotion dans ce lieu
chargé d'histoire.
-"Pour comprendre le jargon
"des militaire, il faut..."
-Il faut beaucoup travailler,
parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'acronymes.
Il faut se former
et beaucoup discuter avec eux.
J'en apprends encore tous les jours.
-Enfin,
"Quand Geneviève Darrieussecq
"quittera le gouvernement..."
-J'aurai le plaisir
de rentrer chez moi, à Sanguinet,
et si le conseil municipal
le souhaite,
je reprendrai mes fonctions de maire
comme je m'y étais engagé.
-Merci beaucoup.
-Avec plaisir.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA